what's funny about you one time i'm not
legit i remember you trying to show me
how fast you were
boxing and i'm sitting there going kev
i'm a 40 year old white comedian
like this is not impressive you should
be able to touch me
this is not we were in some stupid
parking lot and he's going
hey you doing all this stuff i'm just
like all right kev you're fast i get it
you almost seem taller when you're doing
that kev well it's amazing
hey i remember man i don't think there's
anybody that i can annoy
more than bill burr i have i have
probably
triggered some of bill burr's angriest
reactions
in the new york city comedy club no i'm
talking about of annoyance
i remember bill you were when we were
teasing you once
no no patrice patrice used to piss you
more than keith
no all right you're right i was probably
in fourth fifth place
no you were you came in quick yeah
definitely patrice used to get you
patrice used to get you
for sure and patrice's guy i never
worried about you but patrice
if i knew he was going to be there i
would have like five things to say about
him
like i would came in like blocked and
loaded just
to try and hit him until he was dead
then i would i would be
i'd say all five in the first minute and
then i was [ __ ]
you know what man until this day i still
don't understand how a funeral
happened and they turned it into a
comedy club
until this day patrice o'neill how they
turned it
that funeral was great i mean i've never
i've never seen
anything like that in my life you know
foreign like a pair of jordan ones you
look like you're gonna do a spot at
caroline's
i'm like that's what i said go kev this
is the funeral man you're dressed
thinking you're gonna go do a spot at
state of new york and you see what you
said
you go no bill i'm dressed like the
comic who made it
you said that at a funeral
i was like i know this guy's an [ __ ]
i didn't know he's that much of an
[ __ ]
you almost had me saying well i played
carnegie hall one time i almost said
that at a funeral
for my friend that's how much of an
[ __ ] you are
what the [ __ ] we went to patrice
o'neill's funeral
ladies and gentlemen i mean we had so
many comedians first of all patrice was
one of the most loved guys i mean on the
scene
all right let's not throw too much he
was also one of the most hated too yes
but he was a comics comic he was a
comics comic
the comics loved him if you were funny
you loved him yes if you weren't funny
you hated him
because he let you know that you you
stood no chance in this business
if you weren't funny you stopped working
the village because that's where he was
you stayed uptown you didn't want any
problems with that because he was the
guy to go ugh
this guy oh god who let
i remember eddie if one time said dude
he goes
some nights i'll walk into the cellar
and he'll yell across the room hey eddie
and he goes and i think oh he saw me
[Laughter]
dude like that used to come into the
upstairs at the olive tree they used to
try to pick the first open seat
to just you know slick in and stay away
from them the only other person that i
think holds a candle
to patrice's level of of of
evil within within like that that
angry tone is nick nick apollo
nick the power nick nick is a whole
other level nick is
on stage uh corey holcomb corey holcomb
is [ __ ]
you know amazing dude the [ __ ] that guy
can say
corey holmes made me grab my chest huh
he's made me grab my chest now you know
when you're uncomfortable you just grab
your chest
when somebody says something because you
don't know how like
how to take it corey has made me touch
my chest like oh god oh he just sits
there laughing it's like dude this thing
is literally you have this audience on a
thread right now and that's going to
snap
and they're going to rush the stage and
that's where he starts
that's what that's what he loves
uh amazing there's again you'll talk
about a guy who doesn't get enough
credit
that's corey oh my god oh he's been a
beast for 20 years
but you know what though i don't want to
say that he doesn't get credit because
corey's done well
in his career i think i want to say that
because i said it go ahead kev
trash i get it it's your podcast i mean
listen i mean i just think that he's
done
he's done [ __ ] well corey's been a
headliner okay maybe more white people
should know who he is
right okay there you go
baby lebron what's your problem and i
don't like that you're [ __ ] where
are you what is this set up behind you
what [ __ ] spiritual setting are you
in right now
i you know i have a house and i have
children and i'm a father
what the [ __ ] does that have to do with
church glasses what am i supposed to do
while you [ __ ] guys with your own
vodka line and you have kids it's
[ __ ] hilarious
the showgirls skipping through with the
stripper paw oh that's my son
next to the stripper pool i'm a dad this
is what the [ __ ] house looks like
i'm sorry let me let me put my [ __ ]
hoodie up yo you don't say it just
[ __ ] me crazy out there
[Music]
you